you got innocence Congress a little
slowly Long's and nothing something you
said yes thought yeah see ya to first
royalty uh I mean most when Leonor and
Madeleine speak special about animals if
it's about you know Heston kaneen and
then I get it
nothing more complicated than that so
can Nina nor the meaning the rabbit
that's one of the first words you
learned in Swedish because that's that
they knows little thing we can't live
without the canina very little rabbit
and she can't sleep without it
so it's you know if we don't find ken
and then it's we're not gonna go to bed
that night we walked through Chelsea and
she dropped it
we got home we realized that it wasn't
there I spent two hours getting back and
forth across the street in the rain and
thought I thought the the aterna in the
dustbin I was looking in dustman's
people thought I was crazy but I have to
find it behind oh no I need you just is
just Kalinin it hasn't got a name it's
just just commune just come in do you do
you sing lullabies oh yes all the time
yeah what did you think of mine did you
like my lullaby yeah yes but I was so
surprised that you didn't know that the
blink la la Rana
well you're happy in Sweden there you go
original I of course Norwegians you know
Ringo and see there yes clinker is nicer
probably we have it in Norway as well
and I'm gonna get a lot of problems
because I'm sure this is your lucky day
in a way because we have an
english-speaking guests here so we no
need to do this in a mantastic
and tell me can you uh can you recognise
the fact that people get nervous around
you when you when you went through a
room as a royal person can you can you
sense that the people get sort of you
know sometimes but I try to you know
smile and say hi and bring it back
it's not you know I'm just a normal
person I get nervous when she walks in
the room it must have been sort of
awkward I mean coming into this very
special family being a civilian I mean
it must be didn't you feel sort of I
mean yeah good notice I think I would be
nervous meeting you know England the
Queen for the first time yeah for sure
for sure but you know what in each of
those circumstances they happened in
unexpected way so I wasn't fully
prepared and so that took the edge off
um but there's no how-to book there's no
guide there's no nothing so you have to
learn a little bit on on the flow but
for sure you definitely don't know us
how do you if you if you talk to the
king mmm you're your father-in-law how
do you address it kiza
he's always sir
you know he's sorry yes sir huh she's
mom how do you actually get a princess
how did she make a very good question I
occupy so maybe I pinched myself every
day I fell we met through mutual friends
in New York and we we were basically
living in a way kind of parallel lives
you know I kind of saw something there
she didn't see something that that's
just me but we there was always
chemistry okay laughter sense of humor
that's really the bond that I think most
couples that have to kind of you know
and you're a long time or through some
kind of focus or nervous attention that
sense of humor to take everything a
little bit with the pinch of salt that
helps so that's you make me laugh every
day oh
sodomy not with me that video was so
beautiful about your life and you guys
it was so nice but tell me meeting her
for the first time you were quite sure
quite early
I mean you but what did what did you see
you know I saw I think in a way I think
I I read people well that's a part of my
jobs what I've done and with Madeline
you know you you see that big smile you
see those eyes and she's very outgoing
she's very honest she's very forthcoming
and sweet and welcoming and she
immediately cuz people as you say
nervous around her and so forth and she
dispels that I necessarily wasn't
nervous because we met in a private
setting and but yeah you just see there
gregariousness and it's it's a wonderful
thing so you know what did you think
okay Chris well absolutely the sense of
humor and you know of course Chris is a
very very thoughtful person he's very
very generous and you know he's a true
gentleman and yeah how it has he changed
you yes absolutely
um I feel he felt he makes me feel very
safe and I think we're a good team
together we like kind of the same things
and it's quite easy
have you changed hittin do I don't know
how I yes for sure yeah sure
call me Comic Con exactly where every
now I'll get on the Ross my boyfriend
that tonight
but we all tried to change is each other
a bit don't we I mean perhaps the
clothes the this is the style the
something that oh the clothes is style
that I can't touch him
hey I say something no no no no this is
who I am and that's what I like about
Christie's very much about you know this
is me I'm Chris and Neal and you know
I'm not gonna change and and I love that
I love it have you been changed by a
boyfriend this is so fairytale like by
the way mm no no me and you know
what my boyfriend's a bit older than
we'll quite a bolder than me and
actually I feel like for the first time
in my life so far and that that's why
our relationship work so much is cuz he
already is who he's gonna be but where
is anyone else I've ever been with isn't
quite there yet
so they're always changing a lot and so
I think the key to our success is that
obviously we love each other but I think
our age gap actually really works for me
and my boyfriend but yeah I've changed
loads but I think for the better
it's it's amazing being a real team yeah
rather than being very separate and when
you argue rather than splitting up
actually overcoming stuff it makes you
more powerful and there's such true and
especially now when you have children
it's really being a team you really have
to be strong together yeah you you're
quite different people aren't you I I
mean boom yes and now I would say I'm
definitely the one who's maybe a little
bit more calmer and you can sometimes
you know you creep prisons very
emotional guy we're just Italian Irish
you know there's obviously some former
Sissis there but so you you're more more
temperamental more absolutely I'm so
moody it's terrible so so how's the
Swedish become open yeah how do you deal
with that I mean when he's in one of his
moods
well you know the one who deals best for
is actually in or she just just looks at
him and say hi hi just softens you in a
second yeah cuz who's the most romantic
of you you are yeah
we have been living in in new york in
stockholm and now you live here in
london and you have two kids and so a
lot has happened
one must say it since you met I love it
describe your life here in London how is
it do you live in a house or do you live
in a flat or what kind of life is it we
we you know we live in a very normal
life right now I'm a full-time mom right
now and I enjoy spending most of my time
with the with our little kids and you
mean Chris you work a lot but when
you're at home we try to do fun things
together and the weekends we try to you
know go to the zoo or we go to the local
market and we find some nice you know
local vegetable who cooks the best that
you do do you think I got a feeling it
might be he's pointing at him like that
I don't know can you cook no actually I
I have to admit that I probably had
never cooked a real meal for Chris
I'm a terrible housewife tell me what's
the best if you if you had to cook
something yeah what could that be
Swedish meatballs I was just about which
is the fuzzy now that's absolutely ok
lately well we you know maybe we should
get a little less than going on base and
the first one you're taking out the King
first and says it all right there an
English boy yeah
know for sure I will jump on that and I
think Chris will be very happy if I do
this absolutely no but Chris I must say
he's he's a very good chef so you know I
feel I don't even want to go into the
kitchen because he's kind of this is my
area
you know you say I try to think you know
darling did you need any help I can chop
no no no you're just making messes yeah
precisely and he's very good chef you
know so so what what's your signature
dish if you if you signature dish yeah
if you want to impress oh yeah I think I
am
we like like in the winter we like
making like big soups like a ribollita
our ministry you know your minestrone
recipe is always by default guide thank
you very much absolutely but you know as
we say we've go to the market you I kind
of grew up sometimes in holidays in
Italy and my father's mother came from
Sicily and there it's it's you know you
let the ingredients speak for themselves
you know and you try not to temple with
them so you you know the way I kind of
look at it is what you find guides you
to what you're going to cook and if you
find a great chicken you find a great
bit of veg you let you just let them
tell you what you're going to cook and
you just dictate it from that way so but
I like making different things decision
do you remember the first meal in there
that I cooked for her yeah hmm maybe my
a Leo Leo spaghetti a Leo Leo I think
that's your kind of cook yeah they could
forget all that which is very simple but
it's complicated isn't it
yeah we like a martini it's so simple
but you got to get it so right to make
it work
tell me about Leonor and unknit las'
because we don't know them yet um and
you just started to know them because
they're very very young can you see
their personality already yes I think I
mean especially way with Leonor she you
know it's kind of funny because she her
name is actually it means sunlight or
sunshine and and I must say since the
day she was born she's always had a
smile on her face she always you know
every day she makes us laugh and
she's really a fun little character
she's wild she's everywhere fat okay
well and the worst part about it is she
already knows that she has her father
wrapped around her finger so she she's
got it
Nicholas is is is uh is a gentle soul
he he's had a tough time as of late he
had a little tummy bug then he had a
fever and I he's got a bit of a cough so
but even so you come up to him and he
looks at you and then you smile in the
new smiles and it's all very gentle and
very sweet she's more outgoing than he
is but you know he's only six months so
we'll see that's my conversation so is
it are they like mini used but just the
opposite in a way that's good question I
don't know no I think it's a good blend
of each for sure there's lots of
attributes from each of us in both of
them so I can definitely see some
positively annoy within me you know kind
of huh for sure I was quite outgoing
when I was a kid I think and and you
know stubborn as well and she's you wait
till I get older and you're arguing with
them okay and the bit that they're
beating you it is the pitless you and
you're gonna hear just a minute
you're just faster than me and you're me
and me oh okay and also you become your
own parents oh yeah I mean slowly you
become you have you have you have you
noticed that that you become like your
own mother and you yeah are you I the
same kind of mother that your own mother
was um that's a good question I don't
know really um I think so in some way I
think so and I want you know for me I I
feel that my parents they were so loving
and you know the most generous people I
know but you know they were away a lot
when we were kids
due to their you know obligation as a
queen king and queen and so I I feel
that that I really want to give my full
time right now when with my kids because
that's a part that I that I miss a
little bit and but otherwise yeah is
that a generational thing is that is
that because that was the time Thanks so
absolutely I think our generation we are
much more handsome
the kids especially the fathers I think
you know we're much more hands-on I mean
you you change I don't know how many
diapers you changed every mind me but
but Madeline and and and and Victoria as
well are are if I may say born mothers I
mean it's incredible to watch them with
their kids because it's it's just so
natural and I can see it in cut Phillip
as well because when he's with either
Estelle Lillian or you know he he just
his on the floor and he's playing and
wrestling with them and so all three
really are so warm and kind with the
kids that is it's an amazing thing to
see it in action you you were both well
you are both the youngest yeah I mean
you you grew up with four sisters
oh hi sister sorry five sisters and so I
mean you being the youngest boy they'd
they had you in the trolley and just
know I looked like Mick Jagger when I
was young I had this like long hair I
had these like Oh was these hand-me-down
coats which was bizarre because I'd kind
of like far and then they button the
wrong way around and it was all very
strange but of course looking back at a
new day dressed it well my mother they
yeah and you know looking back and it
was like you know late seventies early
eighties now it looks so cool at that
point it was horrendous but you know um
it was a wonderful thing growing up with
a lot of sisters because they really I
think guide you and I'm you know i mean
i think if women could rule the world
the world would be in a lot better place
than it is today so
just to say I really believe it and so I
think that you know having been with a
lot of strong women in my life that
that's only done many positive things
and are you shaped by being the the the
I mean the little sister do you think
that has shaped who you are yeah I'm
sure it has
that's no families I'm sure and you know
having you mices because our parents
were gone quite a lot you know my sister
she really took on that role of being
the oldest sister she she taught us a
lot of things at early stage and she she
always came up with fun plays and and my
brother he was kind of in between these
strong sisters so it's usually that
happens with the middle child and yeah
and you're still very close with your
yes greatness and like when you
mentioned Estelle and my sister it's so
much fun nowadays you know when we spend
our summer in the in an island called
Ellen and South part of Sweden and it
was so much fun this summer too to see
that you know my sister and I we were
doing the same thing that we've always
done when we were kids but now with our
two daughters and you know we we start
off the day we go we pick their eggs
from the chickens and then we go to the
you know strawberry land and read some
strawberries and then we go riding and
and now we're doing with our daughters
and it's a you can't really find him I
mean you you you grew up in the
limelight and I don't know what what's
your memories like from that I mean
being a child and so much watched by
anyone every move move you made was that
is that a positive memory or is it a
tough memory for you you know I was poor
my parents they always got a headache
when we were you know having you know
family photos or something like that
because I always ran off and I was
always hiding and they always had to
drag me there and I was screaming and I
never really want to be a part of it and
you know one one could think that how
I've had this all my life and
one was thinking what would made it
expect that I would be used to that by
now
to be comfortable you know in front of
people or with photographers or
journalists asking you question but I'm
really not I'm I'm I think in the end of
the day I'm I'm quite shy and I don't
like being in the center of attention
but you know as as an official person as
I am I know that this is something I
have to deal with and I'm I'm struggling
with it I'm working on it and I'm here
today how can you be kept on her down
your way when you read about her when
you read criticism or or just oh
absolutely sure of course I'm her
husband so you know for me I'm very
protective and I know also that the
people writing things you know don't
know who we are you know they've never
met us you might pretend they do but
they've never spent time with us they've
never hung out with us so they may say
things that kind of justify their own
means but aren't really you know true
and you you you get a thicker skin over
time you learn it and you you get to
deal with it but it's always a little
painful official you have to find a
balance because I mean as we all know
media is important and and I finding a
balance and of course it saddens me
sometimes when media might think that
I'm arrogant or you know because I'm not
answering their questions and but it's
that's really not that's really not the
case it's not who I am and and of course
that that upsets me sometimes um but um
yeah we have did it ever happen that you
thought oh I wish she was not a princess
yeah yeah I'm not yeah
because you know there were times when
you know it's interesting in England in
this country and and kind of the
anglo-saxon model we take privacy as a
sacrosanct you know it is god-given
right there's certain things in one's
life private
and you know it's not better or worse
than a Scandinavian model where ever
is very much transparent and shared very
different and in hindsight I was not
aware of that I was not prepared for
that in a way so at some point I would
have been like oh I love this girl and I
fell in love with this girl and I have
to now you know very much adapt my
entire life towards who I fell in love
with and there were times of course when
it wasn't so comfortable that you said I
wish I didn't have to do this
they are little my new times and you
know doesn't matter you have declined
royal privileges I mean you had you
haven't got the title well have you ever
considered the same you know I feel that
like Chris what you said and that if I
can through my title you know point on
important issues that I really think
it's is important we talk about you know
for example children's right I will you
know I have to want to do that and if I
can make a difference by just you know
raising the awareness about sixty views
of children this is something we need to
talk about it's so important and then
I'm proud of being a princess and this
is this is your mother's foundation that
you now work with it's called childhood
tell me I did I mean you've been
involved in a lot of projects what what
has made the strongest personal
impression on you oh that's a tough
question um you know with childhood and
though for those who you don't know it's
it's about the we support the most
vulnerable children as three children
children who lives in alternative care
families at risk and of course children
has been sexually abused and you know my
mom when she founded Charlotte she found
that she saw that nobody talked about
this group of kids it was you know so
taboo and people didn't know really how
to talk about it I think it's still
difficult for people I noticed that some
you know they tune off a little bit when
I start talking about it but again it's
so important that we do address this
problem because there are millions
things are 200 million of children out
there who are being sexually abused and
you know only in the US I think one of
10 children are being abused before the
80 85 percent of these kids are 11 years
or younger so for me knowing that
there's so many kids out there who are
sexually abused and exploited and it
makes me even more determined that we
have to do something about it and we
can't do you know how we can perfect the
role of a modern princess um the the
press criticizing you I would interpret
it differently they would interpret that
you should also be available to to the
press yeah yeah can't cut more ribs yes
that's exactly I know I and I understand
it and I'm I'm I absolutely think I
should do I can do both and I see myself
you know now living here in England um I
feel that I could do much much more for
Sweden abroad I can promote you know
Swedish companies they're a huge market
here in UK and I think we're were fifty
thousand Swedes living in London so
there are lot of things I can do here so
you what you're saying you could do more
absolutely
she's being a full-time mum that's
better been a princess in my opinion
do you have any even though you haven't
got the title do you have any
limitations as a businessman in your
business I mean you're a businessman
you're an investor
do you feel that you this role being her
husband gives you some limitations it
did in my previous job and that's part
of the reason a small part of the reason
why I left that job because the we were
managing capital on behalf of clients
and they weren't comfortable and they
kind of the intrusion of the press into
my life and so now I've had to adapt
what I do in so far that it's really
business-to-business type of business
and therefore you're speaking to large
institutions they're multinationals
outside of certain geographic markets
they don't know who I am at all so you
know it doesn't really come into I don't
think it's really ever come up in what
I've been doing for the last three or
four years Who I am or what I do so that
that's a plus side about it what is it
you do really I mean you know sure it's
good answers good question so I sat
behind four computer screens for like 20
years of my life I was just trading and
while I was okay what I did and I liked
what I did and I enjoyed it it was time
for me to not do that anymore
and so I basically spent a lot of my
time focusing on two industries one was
payment processing and one was energy
and now I've identified two
opportunities in those two industries
that I am trying to exploit and and and
make some business from these are
long-term contracts dealing with very
very big companies and so it takes time
to win them it's very frustrating
sometimes because you you you know you
have a solution that would really fix
problems that they have but you know
trying to make a Titanic move takes time
and before before we wrap up tonight I
liked what I did not sorry I I really
that was that was that was a couple
thing
because you're here you had there's not
not not the problem but you had one here
down there she was like yes let's talk
about the future because many people
won't know what's going to happen
I mean how long are you staying in
England you've been as I mentioned
living in New York in in Stockholm
forever for a bit and now in London are
you are you staying here forever
or what's the plan well what who should
I ask I don't know I really we're
looking at each other um you know right
now it's a very good place for us to be
because of Chris your business and you
know I find London it's a perfect place
because it's close to home to my family
and then my friends so it's easy for me
to pop over whenever um New York was a
little bit far away I'm sure you maybe
felt the same thing having family here
and so do you do you have a do you have
a like Scandinavian home here or do you
have have you gone totally British with
you know carpet on the bathroom floor
and everything but that thing you don't
really understand
I don't know carpet in my
we like white clean surfaces
canadian-style well it's probably thanks
to IKEA anyway really like it probably
was all carpets in the 80s
no I think we have a mix mix they answer
Leonore is is starting school when she's
six years old
well what do you think I mean what
should be do you do have we don't think
we don't really six years is is four
years from now so you know what we do is
we we we lay out different you know kind
of alternative options and we
pre-register and do all the things that
one has to do and have spreadsheets come
out I mean in this country I don't I
mean it's incredible you know I've had
I've had schools say no you're on the
wait list because you should have phoned
24 hours after birth yeah you know I
told when I was pregnant I should have
done it but when I had it later died she
died when I was pregnant bearing in mind
that I just went to the local school
around the corner it's a revelation to
me all that not putting their names
there now they've even got a name yeah
so you know we we what we've done is
we've said look let's let's consider
every eventualities plan accordingly and
take it as as it comes yeah I think it's
a portal to see you know what's what's
best for the kids in the end of the day
and take it from there ya know a near
future Christmas coming up how do you
plan to to celebrate Christmas we are
actually celebrating Christmas here with
Chris family I see well yeah when
stocking and everything or do you do
stockings I don't know yeah well we
we're weird
in our family we we celebrate on the
24th because my mother in the Germanic
side of us so we actually do it more
kind of in a German style so we don't
have stockings we have Christmas trees
and things like this but obviously but
we celebrate on the 24th and um but
we're gonna be in Sweden for most of
December and then we come back and have
Christmas early we'll enjoy a little bit
of a Swedish Gold the class meter if you
have it you Tabo do you know where that
is
yes you know smorgasbord I'm sure yes
yeah love it yeah Jude bood is something
that's very typical oh yeah a lot lot of
meatballs lots of me
sausages and lots of the herrings sovery
and what else do we have that this
smoked salmon and gravlax lived face a
little bit weirder things going on good
I'll tell you what about you
I think we're spending it here and in
England and yeah Turkey I make a really
good Brussels back Ratan
because I hate Brussels sprouts here
it's for a double cream though Jamie at
and it's an American eat um I tend to
make like a blueberry sort of pie thing
that's amazing so yeah last chocolate
flight 16 people the turkey didn't fit
in the oven I'd sit with it back against
the oven it was a nightmare like for a
we go get you a bigger oven Delia donut
you're gonna do hello for us yes your
bad is waiting yes thank you so much for
because real pleasure to meet you on
you